et pour cette émission spéciale années
90 il me fallait des chroniqueurs
vintage vous ai trouvés dans les années
90 ne savait pas encore ce que voulait
dire les termes à pension alimentaire
[Rires]
si tu es quand même et puis il a fait le
grand chelem il a tout appris et passera
à la postérité pour avoir été le premier
à oser mixer veste cette poule et
balayage californien benjamin castaldi
expliquez-moi le le projet juge alors
excusez moi mais c'était la mode à
l'époque n'ont pas du tout en france que
cette photo a été prise à l'elysée
monsieur le fait d'être remise de légion
d'honneur d'honneur et c'était pour
qu'ils violent alors c'était pour la
mère de marie france brière et des
produits bachelor années 90 justement et
donc quand on était 80 c'est comme ça
que vous faites honneur et attendait que
j'étais un effort là bon les cheveux
s'est passé c'est pas génial et un
balayage déjà c'était californien de
surcroît laquelle il faut parce que j'ai
des fans de christophe lambert l'époque
[Applaudissements]
les années 90 on l'a retrouvé au premier
rang des concerts d'alliages un soir la
jeter sa culotte sur scène il photos et
une commotion cérébrale
parce que comme on peut voir ici
attendait dans sa chambre d'hôtel
[Applaudissements]
la photo parce que là on dirait la photo
fait pas un serial killers très vite
j'attendais simplement dans cette fois
c'était un hôtel à monaco pardon mais
surtout n'a pas bougé qu'elle change de
ces vieilles
sandra peu à côté
sébastien après sur le sujet alors vous
ne saviez peut-être pas mais nous avons
tourné à table un homme qui dans les
années 90 était reporter de guerre
oui dans la première partie de sa vie ça
donne à beaucoup travailler
c'est pour ça que depuis mi temps il se
repose beaucoup beaucoup l'homme au polo
rouge jean michel maire gm a vu ses
latéraux et montrez moi j'ai celle là je
la montre pas non plus c'était où ça je
pense et en centrafrique je crois mais
je pas sur ses villes savent vous a
jamais dit qu'il fallait pas faire la
photo avec le soleil en plein les yeux
et plein de cheveux
oui la cedh est vrai à l'époque c'était
la première poussée la praire bab drib
90 de 30 ans très mignon parce que c'est
vous un petit faible en un jour mais
ouais c'est vraiment super pote
non non c'est pas mon genre mais il n'en
irait mieux maintenant franchement
d'accord vieilli mais humble et vieillit
bien c'est facile quand on parle pays
vieillit bien à bas le suivant aussi vit
bien parce que il est né en 1987 un an
dans les années 90 il va faire ses
devoirs il va se coucher
c'est le seul enfant de 7 ans qui dès
qu'il parlait en faisait 42
à l'époque il n'avait qu'un seul
objectif le jour de son anniversaire que
son nom apparaisse à la fin du générique
du club dorothée
maxime guinea
[Applaudissements]
c'est en 1993 elle est plus fort de la
bulle autour du chocolat me reste plus
rien c'est bon là on était beau ce cas
vous avez un message à faire passer à
maxime et mieux la musique déficit je
suis moche aujourd'hui sa plus c'est un
peu quand même
je préfère la hamada vous aviez six ans
très exactement aux adhésions la main
quand même hein et la télévision
énormément
hélas dans les années 90 et caresser son
chien la télé et faisait des cartons
d'audience
non je parle pas de michel drucker mais
du seul animateur qui ressemblait comme
deux gouttes d'eau julio iglesias or
voilà bernard montiel
alors on peut pas eu son on était chez
plein de photos mais qui des beaux
gosses away et tout le temps il a pas
bougé photochimique ouais j'suis bien de
loin non non ça va ça va vous êtes à
côté lui est ce qu'il est bien de leur a
aussi oui moi je les ai connu cette
époque les années 90 déjà à montrer ses
gambettes et porter des décolletés
allant jusqu'au nombril
si on lui demandait elle nous dirait
qu'à l'époque était très comestible
c'est lui ressembler à esmeralda dans
notre dame de paris
isabelle morini bosc alors que vous
m'expliquiez parce que là déjà vous avez
deux montres à wigan on vous en avait
quatre attendiez vous est fier qu'une
horloge devant alors cette photo
hennissements c'est un floride avec jean
pierre foucault avec david hallyday avec
julien clerc avec mme annick sauvé mike
connors ce wave draguer l'époque de sûr
j'étais enceinte je le savais pas et
j'emmerde tout le monde en me disant
pendant dix jours
pourvu que ce soit pendant 5 pourvu
qu'ils soient pas en simple ce qui fait
que les gens fiers parce que vous alliez
faire l'amour avec jean pierre foucault
avec madix avec un manic d'eau en
floride
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mathieu ah non elle et moi cette photo
un langage claudia cardinale mais
y'avait y avait déjà un petit barresi un
peu à peu des nues meuse quoi
à chaud ce qui n'est quand même un peu
coquine c'est ce à quoi vous êtes
traversy de soldats tués au début des
années 90 il n'était encore qu'un jeune
homme sans histoire se destinant à une
carrière d'analyste financier c'était
avant qu'il ne rencontre l'amour en se
regardant dans un miroir
[Rires]
matthieu delormeau on voit ça on dit
heureusement qu'ils avaient une ceinture
parce que sinon un problème avec la
thune
cette forte alors double helix non mais
le raid et attend me dit il porte à
gauche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
rappelez vous dans ces années là d un
petit peu connue ont planté tout nu
excelle dans tous laissés pour très
large des ministres à l'art des jeans
501 trop large et comme j'étais tout
maigrichons mais vraiment maigrichon
jusqu'à l'âge de je pense 20 ans je
devais faire
67 kg un truc comme ça vaut une taille
de parce que préciser quand même oui à m
86 où j'allais tout droit des gens pour
ce qu'ils ont fait un mètre 65
non non non c'est vraiment après je suis
venu très beau mais selon ce que les
autres vous allez me dire écoutez pas
les rumeurs indiquant les années 90 elle
aurait pu faire partie du casting classe
mannequin et finir en poster relations
du petit maxime gainey à l'époque elle
avait beaucoup de mal à boutonner ses
chemises justine fraioli
elle
or en la gauche molle
ce que j'ai dit on sait qu'on va
demander à chacun d'envoyer années 90 l
on voit ça c'est quoi sa faute à moi
parce que je pense que ramon dossier des
lieux 90 et donc je me suis dit tiens
ils vont le ressortir c'est sûr donc
autant que je sente la carte 98 97 98 ou
là ça allait j'ai eu des années 90 est
extrêmement difficile physiquement on va
y revenir au talon on a un petit dossier
sur eux avec un gros même on peut dire
non non ça ne se voyait pas trop alors
vous savez ce que c'est aujourd'hui
c'est aux donateurs un gros bâton pour
dire comme ça on affiche elle ressembler
à quoi l'animatrice dans les années
quatre gardes bad boy et son petit
blouson pour jouer les durs à regarder
[Applaudissements]
alors déjà le mec accueillons le temps
vient d'être tout de suite
souriant c'est un bus à bréval n'avait
pas changé d'un iota un franchisé rendez
vous chez l'ophtalmo mais ça fait
plaisir
amy est en chaleur là il s'était déjà
rien moi c'est encore mieux aujourd'hui